and kyrie
moments ago
giving love to the crowd and then
showing off his handle
and there is a palpable
buzz
in the building here in brooklyn tonight
look at how quickly they wanted to come
back on offense
[Applause]
rings the bell that's the pace you want
right there
[Applause]
he'll probably
guessing here come off the bench once
simmons comes back
mellow again second three ball for the
20 year old
the metal ball has got 15 points miles
princess got 17. they're your two
leading scorers lamelo relocates and
hits the three
[Applause]
[Music]
durant misses the drummond misses the
follow hornets have numbers five on four
open man is lamelo got it again
six quickies for number two here in the
third quarter nope hornets again with
the basketball in the lead
lavalo
from
his
piscataway
straight triple
horns playing quick on this end
mile through the dark into cody back out
to lamello
oh
[Applause]
falling on his wallet
[Music]
that will do it
a very
disappointing
loss
in kyrie irving's home debut
the hornets have the tiebreaker and the
nets droop tonight in the eastern
conference standings